i don't know what was tougher
seeing michael chandler fight dan hooker
or then having to
watch michael chandler do a backflip off
of the cage
i don't know which one was harder for me
i don't know which
if i would rather have to fight dan
hooker
or do a backflip off the cage man
both looked extremely very insane
um but kudos to michael chandler man on
his victory and
probably the greatest ufc debut of all
time
to come right out and and a lot of time
in ufc they'll do
there's a bit of a dance in the
beginning
you know there's a bit of a non
kind of a non non-dancing capoeira of
of sorts of violent capoeira
but michael chandler didn't do that he
came straight out
like that dog like a you know
like a poor person neighborhood dog in
the in the in the 90s that thing
and ain't gonna smell you first man
it'll bite
so i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been